hi everyone welcome to the third
tutorial in our imaging science series
at the MIT Museum my name is Brian Myrna
and I'm the education coordinator at the
at the Museum and today we're going to
be looking at high speed photography if
you haven't done so already please check
out our earlier tutorials on camera
settings and macro photography
especially the camera settings those are
going to be referenced a lot in this
video so what we're going to be seeing
today is how do you take these images
for example the ones I have below of
like the high speed water drop the balut
water balloon popping on the right how
do you capture these images using the
photography equipment that you have to
start let's take a picture of a box fan
now for reference I have a picture of
the fan wall it's not moving and you can
see what the blades of the fan look like
now if I turn the fan on and try to
capture the fan blades wallach spinning
I'm going to end up with something like
this so in this example I use a fast
shutter speed to try to capture that fan
blade as it's moving quickly the problem
with using such a fast shutter speed is
that not much light can get into the
camera very few photons can enter the
camera and reach the center in that
short period of time so we get a dark
image now instead maybe I'm going to try
a longer shutter speed to fix that so if
I use a longer shutter speed a slower
shutter speed I now get a brighter image
but you can see now that the fan blades
are very blurry so as you take the
picture while that shutter is open I'm
going to be capturing the fan as it
moves so both the long shutter speed and
a short shutter speed aren't giving me
the image that I would like ideally I'd
like it to kind of look like as if the
fan wasn't spinning on top of that
there's another issue that we run into
and that is rolling shutter so if you
look closely at this image so this is
one taken at fast shutter speed and so
it's very dark you can see
a little bit better though because I
raised the eye so the result of doing
that is it's a very grainy image you can
see all the kind of random colors in
here but what I want you to focus on is
if you look at the distance between the
fan blade so the bottom fan blades here
look like they're farther apart than the
ones on top the fan blades are a little
distorted if you look back at our
reference image
all of these fan blades are evenly
spaced this distortion effect is known
as rolling shutter to see this a little
more clearly I'm going to try to take
the same picture but using a flash so
the flash is going to give us more light
so it'll fix part of our problem with
there not being enough light in our
picture but there's also a very strange
effect as I increase the shutter speed
so I'm starting at a three twentieth of
a second and increased to one eight
hundredths of a second to freeze that
motion to get rid of any motion blur you
can see this black line in my photo and
it's getting larger and larger this is
again due to the rolling shutter effect
so let's take a look at what causes this
and once we understand it we can figure
out how to avoid it the shutter can work
in two different modes so here you see
the center of the camera and we're going
to put the shutters over that so
normally before you take a picture the
shutter is closed and you notice there's
actually two parts of the shutter right
here and these are going to move in
different ways so when you first take a
picture at most slow shutter speeds so
usually if you're below a three
twentieth of a second so it's longer
than a three twentieth of a second so
what's gonna happen is when you hit the
shutter button one leaf of the shutter
is gonna drop down and open the shutter
and then following that the second blade
is going to close for the fraction of
time that you set
and that works again as I said up to
about three twentieth of a second once
you get faster than that it's going to
work a little bit differently so what's
going to happen here is if you do a
faster shutter seed let's say one one
thousandth of a second the shutter
instead of opening all at once is going
to open just a little bit and then both
shutters are going to move down the
center like this in a scanning motion
now you may think this might be a little
weird right different parts of the
sensor are going to be detecting photons
at different times and this is why we
see the effects of the distorted fan
blades or the bands in the images that
we just looked at for example when using
the flash in the images the flash turns
on and off very quickly so it turns on
part of the image is being recorded but
then as the shutter moves the flash is
already off so the remainder of the
image is dark now there's something you
may also be thinking is well if you're
taking a picture with a cell phone it
doesn't have a mechanical shutter it
doesn't have these pieces of plastic
that move in front of the center it's
too small and so what a cell phone will
do is in order to take a picture with a
cell phone you need to be able to see
the image before you take it there's a
live feed you can see the light coming
in to the camera but in order for you to
see a live picture before you take the
pictures you can see what you're trying
to image you need to capture photons and
compute do computations on that data and
put it on the screen very quickly the
camera is not fast enough the cell phone
is not fast enough to do that all at
once so what the cell phone actually
does is it scans just like that rolling
shutter I just showed you and it's going
to scan line by line so it's going to
record the data where this green line is
and it's going to start display
as it scans the next line and it's going
to scan and display scanned and display
and it's gonna go like this and this is
also going to cause that rolling shutter
effect the rolling shutter effect
especially in an electronic shutter also
has a very interesting effect in video
so if you watch here as I move the
camera back and forth lines that should
be parallel and vertical straight up and
down
become slanted and distorted so now that
we understand how the shutter works in
our cameras we can look at well how can
we avoid these problems in order to take
some super sharp high-speed photos so
look let's imagine we're gonna take a
picture
and we're gonna put this camera in a
completely dark room so there's no light
in this room and when we turn on our
shutter let's set our shutter speed to
be very long let's say one minute if my
camera is in a very dark room so what
what is it going to capture well even
though the shutters on for a very long
period of time one minute if there's no
light in the room we're not going to
capture anything but a dark image
because there's no light entering the
camera now during that time what if we
turned on a flashlight let's say for one
second
what are we gonna see well if we turn
that flashlight on for one second but
have a shutter speed of one minute in
the dark room we're only going to
capture a light from when that light was
on the rest of that shutter speed we're
not going to be capturing any light this
is going to allow us to avoid that
rolling shutter effect by having long
shutter speeds but also freeze things by
strategically choosing a light source
now you may be asking how do I get a
perfectly dark room and it may not be
possible to have it 100% dark but one
thing you can do is adjust your camera
settings so here what we're gonna want
to do is take our ISO and drop that as
low as possible
the lower you can get your ISO the less
ambient light from around the room
you're going to capture and the darker
the room is going to be your camera is
going to be only sensitive to that
bright light that we're going to end up
producing so in that way of a darkroom
or we've adjusted our camera settings so
we have a relatively dark room we now
need a light source and so for a light
source we want to pick something that
can turn on and off very very quickly
the amount of time that the light is on
is now going to be essentially our
shutter speed so no matter how long our
shutter is open so again let's say we
have it open for 10 seconds if our light
flashes on and off for a ten thousandth
of a second don't lean on for a tiny
tiny bit of time then that's basically
our shutter speed a ten thousandth of a
second and we can capture things very
quickly without worrying about rolling
shutter there are a few different ways
to do this the simplest is to use your
cell phone and you can actually use the
LED on the back of your phone that you
usually use as a flashlight with an app
and if you just search for strobe light
apps you can turn that led into a strobe
light so this strobe light it'll flash
on and off very quickly but what really
matters is how long that light is on and
a lot of these apps you can adjust that
and get a very short flash duration
another option is if you have a camera
flash so if you have a regular flash for
a camera and you set this to the lowest
power you're going to get a flash
duration of about one ten thousandth of
a second so now your shutter speed is
one ten thousandth of a second no matter
what the shutter speed on your camera is
actually setup if you want to go even
faster and catch things that are faster
than ten thousandth of a second or if
you're taking pictures with the
cellphone and can't set up a regular
camera flash you can also use a strobe
light you want to make sure that the
sure light has
a filament instead of LEDs the filament
flashes are on for shorter periods of
time than LED flashes but what this
strobe light does is the light turns on
and off within one millionth of a second
so using a strobe light and you can find
these online fairly cheap you can get
shutter speeds of essentially one
millionth of a second and capture things
that happen very very quickly so now
let's look at a few examples otos and
see what some example setups look like
when using strobe or high-speed
photography
so the first three photos here are water
dropped photos taken in different ways
some are with a flash summer with a
camera flash somewhere with a strobe
light they're using different cameras
and on the right here we have a popping
water balloon this one's also using a
regular camera flash for the setup what
I recommend is having the light source
at 90 degrees to where you're taking the
picture so you can see in the lower left
that we have the camera set up as a
strobe light so this black black phone
here is being used as the strobe light
and then we're taking the taking the
picture with this other light the 90
degree having them 90 degrees together
will give you a really nice exposure but
feel free to experiment with that by
changing the light angles light from
above below different angles use
different colors those are all going to
give you very different effects in the
second image on the bottom we have a
similar setup with dropping dropping
water except now we're using a DSLR with
a traditional camera flash now this is
straight on to the photo so we're going
to get a different look a different look
in our photo in terms of lighting but
this will also work in the third picture
on the bottom we are using the strobe
light and you can see in this this blue
image here on the top this water drop
image it's also cropped in its was
basically taken the same as the image on
the left but it's been cropped in so you
can see all of that detail
we've also added
food coloring and that gives a very
different look so add food coloring
tried all sorts of different experiments
here and we'd love to see what you come
up with thank you for joining us for
this tutorial in our imaging science
series with the MIT Museum and Koch
Institute we'd love to see your stunning
science photos if you'd like to share
them with us you can show them on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and use
the hashtag MIT em imaging science to
share those with us at the end of this
program so on June 20th will be holding
a webinar to look at what makes a great
science photo and some of the so
submissions have a chance to be featured
during that webinar for more information
on the imaging science program other
tutorials and other information and
resources please visit the MIT Museum
website at the link below
and you will find a list of our other
resources as part of the Imaging Science
program